has been waiting here for more than 80
hours hoping to find her loved ones
her son daughter-in-law and grandchild
are still under this Rubble
this Rubble
this Syrian family has six relatives in
the same collapsed building they fled
the Civil War and came to karaman
maharash to begin a new safer life here
this Turkish and Syrian families are now
sharing the same pain
people are trying to cope
they are relying on Aid and sleeping in
cars as the aftershocks continue
God shall save us we are now refugees
she says
death and life are intertwined here
as survivors are provided food the dead
bodies keep arriving
this was one of the largest stadiums in
karaman maharash
it has now been turned into a tent city
for those who survived
it houses 3 000 people around 15 in each
tent
durna and her family moved in this tent
a day ago
she says she and her three children had
to survive Sub-Zero temperatures for two
days when her home was heavily damaged
some of her relatives also died in the
disaster
foreign we are safe as much as a tent
can defend us kids are cold at night I
have a three-year-old son he is scared
as soon as the tent shakes and runs
towards me asking is it happening again
the residents here are served food and
warm clothes but at night the weather is
extremely cold
they say they struggle to stay warm
especially the children
as the sun sets a body is found
[Applause]
her son has been pulled out from under
the rubble but he is not alive